do you believe that
a satanic cabal is in charge of the
united states
i think there's a satanic cabal running
the world
yes and and when you say that like davos
and the world economic forum who are
some of the satanic individuals
well
you've seen a few of them already
they're they're they're not hiding it
you look at any profile high profile
artist
you
you know from the clinton camp
uh i believe barack obama has been
involved in some of it
but you look at the soros's
you look at the rockefeller
types
um
but then but then
but mike let's really i want because
sometimes people are so vague
rockefeller types so i mean let me just
ask you is george soros demonically or
satanically possessed
i don't know you don't know is barack
obama
i don't know but you just listed both of
them have you ever asked them no i've
not spoken i've never asked them but who
am i right but what i'm saying is i can
only look at their actions and do you
believe that their actions are evidence
of satanic possession
i don't know but then why are you
bringing their names up because they're
trying to destroy humanity okay who are
the rockefeller types you mentioned
well you've seen them
i i'm not going to get into to to name
dropping right now i'll we'll deal with
that later on who will deal with it
though it seems we would want to know if
you have the list i want to know who
these people are well if you would get
me the
the jeffrey epstein galen maxwell list i
could probably point to a lot of them
mike i got to ask you a serious question
here and i hope you don't take offense
are most of these satanically possessed
people either black or jewish because
you're naming a lot of black and jewish
people
i don't know their ethnicity
you don't know obama's ethnicity well i
is he
i don't know
what he claims to be one thing and he's
but he's also playing uh claimed
publicly to be another thing what do you
mean
well is he a us citizen is he an african
citizen is he you know
you know this gives back to the whole
you know birth certificate uh argument
oh my god i don't i don't have a an
opinion on it i just know that this man
has has presented himself to be one way
and then his actions were entirely
another way he's been the most divisive
uh hate-filled president we probably had
ever had until joe biden which is really
joe you know obama 3.0 wow so you don't
know what what about soros and epstein
did you know that they're they're jewish
i i don't care
you don't i don't care i don't care what
they are i'm judging them by their
actions more the content of the
character than the color of the skin
so it's a very superficial argument to
bring in can satanic possession be cured
well if you remove the possessor i guess
so yeah how is that done though
well
biblically it would be through an
exorcism or something of that nature wow
that sounds
extremely serious
well are you demonically possessed
not that i'm aware of do i seem it to
you no okay
i'm just saying it sounds like an
exorcism is very serious
well
i would say that anyone who's bent on
destroying the human race yeah is
probably in league with the one that you
would say is the enemy of the human race
and that would be satan himself
wow
this is bumming me out mike i'm not
gonna lie this is a sad outlook it's
it's making me uh sad about about
humanity but but look what just occurred
david yeah we got assaulted by a virus
and then a vaccine we were misled by
we've got a green new deal that's going
to destroy and collapse the u.s economy
and that's just the u.s look at what's
going on in europe look what's going on
in asia it's a concerted effort to thin
the world of humans dear god and then
but now on the other end of that
what's the goal why thin the world of
humans who benefits
well if you see people like you and i
yeah in god's image as your enemy well
then then you know that's a victory for
you
you just get rid of the of the bad
people essentially and enough to have
sort of an army of slaves which is if
you take communism at its truest form
that's just a small group of people
controlling a very large group of people
through fear
and dependency so we're looking at a
world of slaves that's being run by a
few people
and they're okay they seem to be okay
with slavery as long as they get to be
the new masters and that's where your
your color component comes in because
it's really not color dependent it's who
gets to play the master this time around
and we have i believe more slaves now in
the united states because of our open
southern border and our ports of entry
being wide open than we've ever had and
my opponent is one of the chief wow
chief uh
you know supporters of the wide open
border and i believe is responsible for
a lot of the human trafficking that has
come out of particularly guatemala
but well mike listen i have not seen
evidence of that i will investigate it i
have to say in total honesty
some of this stuff is pretty out there
even for the republican party so i sort
of understand the unendorsement this is
this is some pretty out there stuff that
you're you're saying
but
just saying it's out there doesn't mean
it's not true it just means you haven't
come to terms with it that's absolutely
correct